oh do you think people dreaded scene
were you always like too much of a party
for the scene no no people love me
people love me yeah
I could find something by doing Lubbock
Texas on a Sunday night brother
that's hard to do yeah somewhere
somewhere there's a victim
S I just need to start the conversation
and what was this
who does
ha
who else could drink like that with you
who could really oh God name it that's
that endless double A Mike eggstrand
Piper a drinking guys are there's a lot
of guys can really drink yeah
did you ever try to stop drinking well I
guess after your sir after your after
that well I didn't drink for a year he
didn't drink for a year and then one
time I was taking steroids then I took
an overdose of one and my heart went
like this and the guy said uh you've
been drinking too much you thought I had
cardiomyopathy so I did an old duelistly
here
it's not hard for me to quit drinking it
was hard it brought me a rehab I had no
problem quit drinking
what did you how long were you in rehab
for 35 days and you where'd you go to
place your own Tampa oh that's nice yeah
Florida has Fuller every every other
building in Florida oh yeah this is it
was a
an old uh
um
no not a Days Inn but La Quinta oh yeah
oh yeah over here on Fowler right yeah
so my roommate my roommate's a doctor
from Fort Lauderdale that is there for
digesting
uh uh crystal meth anally oh that's one
roommate now what's that got to do with
me drinking the other one the other one
is the other guy is the 23 year old that
was taken 40 milligrams of Valium
at 23. you don't think he would vibrate
in the other guy I'm trying to think
[Music]
um
the other guy I don't know what the hell
he did but I mean it was so far-fetched
and here's the deal I get there I go
through all the physical and all that
get all the [__] done right the doctor
checks me out I wake up in the morning
and I when I was a kid I used to smoke
so I I just loaded up with cigarettes
dip I've always dipped my whole life
I've quit playing and I don't dip
anymore but I you will again though that
I might well but it's just nasty it's
different you know oh yeah I don't like
it but you do it yeah but um I look
across the courtyard I'm smoking a
marble right and I'm bringing a cup of
coffee and I said I said to the guy my
roommate I can't remember his name so
that's not the guy that guy looks just
like a doctor he said as a doctor
I said what are you doing here it's been
a patient here for five years I said the
doctor is taking care of us in the
[__] patient
what I couldn't believe it say welcome
to the counselor is that [__] guy did
he have a license no they pulled it well
how was it how is he practicing medicine
he lives in that house I was in the
[__] night house
I mean I cried I went this is The Nut
House I'm full of nuts
when the doctor is taking care of you
give me a shot prescribing medication
is and he's there for he's a five-year
vet
and he's a patient and he's a patient
and he's taking care of me
oh my God who wrote that script I don't
know that's what I said to him holy [__]
wow oh my God damn right you're not
allowed talking to the girls we're like
okay
that's how they want you to take your
test again what does this look like a
bear or a skunk or a an owl it looks
like you dumb [__] why are you asking me
the same question I've been looking at
this box for three days three weeks and
I'm not gonna change I don't know what
it looks like
what does it look like to you and why
are you in here
yeah
I'm lying
no [__] and did y'all do any Athletics
in there do y'all do like volleyball no
one guy told me I missed the morning
walk and we went to The Big Meet and I
threatened to kill him I said next time
you still jump me a [__] I'll
find you before we get here
because the weather thing anybody want
to talk oh the circle before you go to
bed
God circled jerk
God man no no [__] it was brutal
you can have this you can frame it say
Ric Flair was here and give me six
Miller lights and two Jack and Coke and
two uh Kettle One and cranberry and lime
crack them all right there then uh then
I had a limo pick me up and take me over
to the beach yeah yeah oh you got to go
for a swim after that oh Jesus I wasn't
kidding what was was there ever any like
wild you're not supposed to drink
okay
oh wow that room they faked me out with
that for a while the company will never
have your back work if you don't go back
and rehabit you said you go back I'm not
going back yeah well company number
years ago okay fine two weeks later you
come over to TV yeah of course I thought
it wasn't allowed to come anymore you
are
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one